de las 5 coordenadas de los puntos a b c
d
en la siguiente línea numérica cuál
tiene el valor absoluto más grande bueno
el valor absoluto más grande tendrá que
ser aquel que esté más lejos de cero y
en este caso va a ocurrir aquí en los
lugares por lo que estoy viendo va a
ocurrir en el punto a menos 2 y en el
punto de 2 ya que el valor absoluto de
menos 2 es 2 y el valor absoluto de 232
entonces va a cumplir para estos dos
puntos
estoy viendo las opciones
podemos tener más una respuesta correcta
vino la respuesta se de este examen dice
que es la opción pero este es falso
también se cumple para él porque estamos
hablando de los valores absolutos más
alejados xixona y en eso no hay vuelta
bueno a lo mejor se equivocaron de a
cinco coordenadas de los puntos a b c d
ye en la siguiente línea numérica cuál
tiene el valor absoluto más grande
definitivamente el valor absoluto más
grande es 2 en nada y n estos son
iguales
vamos a dejarlo así pero creo que aquí
sí se equivocará veamos el siguiente
problema si x y que son números primos
cuál de los siguientes no puede ser la
suma de xy bueno entonces nos dicen que
x y james son números primos
soy el número primo significa que sólo
puede ser divisible entre sí mismo y 1 y
nos preguntan cuál de estos números no
puede ser la suma de estos dos números
primos eso es lo que nos pregunta
ahora vamos a resolver esto veamos el 5
el 5 puedo hacer la suma de el número
primo dos y el número primo tres esto da
cinco ok del 9 el 2 ya vemos que es
primo el 7 también es primo y dos más 7
nos da 9 así que este no es el 13
el 11 es número primo ya vimos que el 2
es número primo 11 más los estreses y
que éste tampoco puede ser y el 11 es
número primo el 5 también es número
primo así que esto es 16 esto tampoco es
y bien estas opciones pues elijo la aún
cuando lo he encontrado cuáles son los
valores de xy 1 debe ser rápido en estos
exámenes y elegir la opción correcta y
de los números primos que tengo en mente
ninguno al sumarse entre sí puede dar 23
así que esta es la opción correcta
veamos el siguiente problema problema
número 22 si cada una de las siguientes
fracciones se escribirá como un decimal
que se repite cuál sería la secuencia
más larga de dígitos diferentes bueno
analicemos cada una de estas opciones
muy bien veamos la opción b que es un
tercio esta no puede ser porque 1 entre
3 es igual a 0.3
3333 eso sigue de manera infinita así
que este se repite sólo un dígito de
esta opción no es
tampoco es la opción de esto tampoco es
porque 2 entre 3 es igual a 0.6 6666 así
hasta el infinito entonces bueno esto no
es veamos la opción a 211 amos veamos
dos voy a poner aquí puntos 0 0 0 entre
ok aquí va a ser punto
11 por 11 11 20 - 11 va a ser igual a 9
bajo este cero
8 aquí 8 x 11 88 90 menos 88 es igual a
2 bajó el 0 aquí volvería a ser 1
de nuevo aquí 11
y quedan 9 y veo que aquí se va a
repetir el ciclo entonces aquí va a ser
punto 18 18 18 así hasta el infinito
entonces bueno aquí tengo estos dígitos
que se repiten para ahora veamos la
opción c
ok la opción c es 41 entre 90
ok la opción se es
41 99
ok la opción c 41 entre 99 vamos a
escribirla por acá
41.000 entre
99 o que íbamos a comenzar aquí con
49 por 436 llevamos 3 9 por 4 36 y 4 que
llevamos
9 x 4 36 y
39 por 4 36 y 3 que llevamos son 39
esto menos
va a ser igual a
14 aquí bajamos un 0 140 ahora pues lo
multiplicamos por 1 140 99
99 va a ser igual a
41 y aquí bajamos el otro 0 y de nuevo
tenemos el 410 así que aquí va a ser
otro 4 sería
396 los restó y me queda de nuevo 14 el
cero y aquí bueno se repetiría el punto
4 1 4 1 4 1 así que en bueno tanto la
opcional como la c tendrían el mismo
número de dígitos que se repite nada más
dos así que todo indica que será el que
tendrá más dígitos
no tiene mucho tiempo pues eligen la
opción y continúen pero aquí en el vídeo
vamos a comprobarlo así que vamos a
hacer la división de 23
punto 000 /
vamos a poner aquí punto 6
esto es igual
222 esto lo restamos es igual a 8
baja aquí
aquí ponemos un 27 por 214 llevamos 12
por 36 17 restamos nos quedan 6 se bajen
ok aquí lo multiplicamos por 1 menos 37
aquí va a ser 3 y aquí va a ser
223 bajaremos otro 0 y aquí se repite
aquí tendremos que poner otra vez 6 aquí
sería 222 la resta sería 8 y así
continuaría de manera que se repite el 6
21 16 21 61 después del punto decimal
así que en efecto nuestra opción
correcta es la veamos el siguiente
problema
en la siguiente figura las coordenadas
del punto son
ok bueno aquí hay que asegurarse de
saber cuánto vale cada una de estas
divisiones en estos ejes veamos 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 este son 7
aquí
unos dos tres cuatro cinco aquí
5 - 5 porque está la parte negativa del
eje de leyes ok entonces este punto de
acabarse eso va a tener coordenadas 7
menos 5
y
es más viendo el punto x está en la
parte positiva y ya está en la parte
negativa así que está en el cuarto
cuadrante hicimos las opciones son la
luna con estas características que es la
opción y esta es nuestra opción correcta
y nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo